all right what are your names zory
Blanca what is it Zori Blanca zory yes
Blanca I'm saying Blanco
hello I'm sorry and sorry yeah I'll
stick with that
um where are you guys from originally
where'd you grow up I'm I'm Flint
Michigan
I'm from Illinois what part small city
outside of Chicago Waukegan
tell me about your family's growing up
you had Mom and Dad
um well my mom and dad
um my mom sent me to my dad when I was
like two so I'll live with my dad okay
um I was pretty much raised by my
grandmother
where is your mom and dad my parents
were mainly incarcerated in and out of
prison is there your your mom gave you a
why because she wasn't ready for kids so
my dad was just his responsibility she
was young or yeah she was young she was
young okay how young was she well I was
17 17. yeah my dad was 19. okay yeah
how would you describe your childhoods
um it was like the black sheep on a
black black sheep so like at least I was
like to myself raised myself or my
sexuality and then being molested by my
mom's brother at what age I'm five wow
yeah so but I didn't like my dad knows I
was 13.
sorry rough Charlotte yeah so I hit it
when I was 16. um he gave me an
ultimatum changed my sexuality or get
out I chose to leave so I've been
hitting the streets since then
hard to ultimatum you can't just change
that yeah I know right
well pretty much me I like I said before
I grew up with my grandmother
um my parents
um sold drugs
so we were like we I experienced like
getting the raid like people get well my
father getting raided and [ __ ] and um my
dad left when I was like 14 and he went
to prison
and my mom it was either him or my mom
that was gonna like because they were
under
um the feds were watching them or
whatever the case may be but
um it was either him or her so she had
to like um you know get on the stand and
you know so I pretty much grew up with
my grandmother no five well my mom and
my dad was always in jail
how far you guys going to school
[Music]
um I graduated and I did some college
yeah yeah but I was um put out of the
city schools so I never made it to high
school so I had to go to job court and I
had to do like the 10th 11th 12th grade
in one year and then I got my nursing
license
while I was doing those three years you
worked as a nurse for all CNA yeah
I had to quit
me um I didn't graduate
um I I dropped out when I was in like
ninth grade
um I started
um
well you guys call the prostitution I
call it
companionship to men
yeah but um exactly yeah
um
yeah so I end up dropping out or
whatever
and I just started Living the street
life because you know my grandmother she
only could afford like certain [ __ ]
growing up and you know I always wanted
the best so you know
um
like I saw
I had to go get it by any means like
that right
where'd you guys meet
oh Flint Michigan hit Michigan Michigan
yeah so you are you call yourself
sisters but you're not really sisters no
yeah you're just friends no that's right
that's why we've been you're our
biological sisters
so your sisters yeah you got it if you
came to La when 2015 2015 yeah
and uh we went to Atlanta first so we
used to take the map wherever the coin
dropped is the city is the state we just
up and just went to like Chicago Detroit
Atlanta L.A yeah you like you like rough
cities
pretty much yeah
so you're staying on skid row now no
um right now um I just got um houses so
we have an apartment now
you've been on the streets before that
yeah I've been for 2016. same year in
the 10th or what yeah
she passed
two years when I got in a relationship
with someone
but before that it was just homeless I
just didn't do the streets the tent
things but I've been homeless since I
was 16. yeah
um
yeah I mean no
no no no tent
um but I pretty much been in the streets
um I just like I said I always hustled
you know kept a room and things like
that
um when we came here like I when I came
well I was staying in Oklahoma and
almost got married to a certified
electrician and you know he found out I
was prostituting and I was with him for
like two and a half years right before I
moved here to La I was here before she
came
so you guys how are you supporting
yourselves now
um right now entertaining men still yes
pretty much
um yeah it's a lot of things I do you
know you can make good money doing that
here yes yes yes with no distraction
do you have distractions
um no I might I'm my biggest distraction
what about drugs drugs yes I double into
that who don't
crystal meth excuse me crystal meth
um I wouldn't necessarily say crystal
meth I'm gonna say
um I'm hardcore with that yeah I live a
fast life yeah
but yeah
no yeah Crystal masses yeah it's a
popular drug with it it is the trans
community that was like the first thing
they asked us when we got off the plane
like it's like the thing to do now I
guess yeah yeah that's not what you do
how you do it I guess
um
are you guys happier in La than you were
in other cities
yeah yeah yeah
it's just way fast yeah I learned a lot
I learned a lot I'd have been to prison
um yeah yeah since I've been here I
didn't crafted it
um a lot of things I've learned I'm
still learning to this day what were you
in prison for
um someone put their hands on me and
talk to me so I altercation say how you
said
um start with a daily weapon I
interrupted you you're saying so you you
uh you've learned a lot of things yeah
what have you learned um like I said
confidence um accomplish a lot stronger
um patience
um
um I was no one said it was a pushover
but I'm like I was I'm very nice so like
I kind of like got this backbone like
um right now I'm just trying to figure
out where what I now I have to figure
out what I like and what I don't like
again from being homeless to going back
to the normal life again
you're like okay so that's not an easy
adjustment no especially you think it
would be but I think it's it's hard for
a lot of people yeah especially when
it's like especially when you're out on
the streets because when we came here we
we the only one we only had each other
you know what I mean so it's great that
you have a good friend in each other oh
yes and it was like kind of hard when
she went to prison like I that like
because we I just started like indulging
in crystal meth or whatever and she
ended up leaving and
um it was like I'm dealing with I'm
around these people that I really don't
want to be around and I'm watching
people like you know try to get me high
to the point where I you know sometimes
you lose yourself off of crystal meth if
you don't you know if you don't do it
the right way
however but you know I I overcame the
battle you know
um
and being trans is much easier here
yeah
um
yes yes they love the life of um of
products because you never really find
um trans that is in a relationship that
is a man that's comfortable
yeah and here the men are comfortable
with being with their trans woman and
and um public despite however they look
they're for them even if they're for
females they're still for the trans so
like that's what I really like about it
there's a lot of people in the jungle
um here I don't even see download even
exists here like because it's not yeah
being bisexual or not even just being
just liking what you like is normal here
liking what you like because it looks
good yeah whatever whatever moves you do
you guys feel like you were always meant
to be trans
um I never looked at as being trans um
because back at home before I
transitioned I was like really not too
um
I really didn't have a lot of
information knowledge on them
but um I always knew that I was female
yeah but you really feel like you were
born that way yeah yeah
um my see my biggest competition Smith
yeah I think it's there
um I I've been I've been transitioning
since I was 16.
um was there any abuse in your childhood
yeah I'm like oh no yes my dad my dad
didn't um he didn't he didn't go for it
like I used to be like terrified of him
like you know and
um
yeah I pretty much I'm accepted at home
but it's like
they had to grow into it you know is
there any sexual abuse in your church
yes
um yeah my mom's friend
weirdo her some her son was a weirdo and
he used to like yeah I suck the dick at
seven uh it's bad I say that but it's
it's true though and it's like
it's scarred me you know it had me doing
things I probably wouldn't normally be
doing you know what I mean but I always
been a girl
you know
are you doing hormones or anything like
that yes I take hormones I've been on
hormones for um since I was 18 on and
off how are they taking female hormones
affect
especially with the um I think she
caught her first case off the world
storm I I kind of just being pregnant
when I was the baby you just have all
the moon swings all the adjustments on
the
um if you're in a relationship the guy
um don't have knowledge on it so he
thinks that you're using that as an
excuse for everything and it's pushing
the buttons and you were taking off
don't know why you ticked off don't know
why you're going but everything is
overboard like when you take off the
littlest thing just piss you off it's
like a pregnant woman you have the same
mood swings as a pregnant woman how old
are you guys I'm 32. I'm 28. mm-hmm
and is it easy to make friends in this
community or is it just you just hang
out with each other where are we from
where are we from we the lgbtq community
is not big in the city where we stand at
but um so it really just been us but the
I just um I just know we never were
really into the LGBT community like that
we always always around our heterosexual
men yeah that that didn't like um that
didn't hang around like who wasn't so
open like that like weren't like
discreet you know yeah and that's where
Dr was at because but there's a lot of
heterosexual men that are into trans
women yeah yes um we're the new things I
attract aisle tracks should have more
heterosexual men than
LGBT community more just because of the
vibe and the the energy like a man want
to give he want to be around you
let me see how that's nice I'm
interesting level so many levels to be
in assuming levels yeah because not
everybody can just you just can't wake
up and be like oh my God I want to be a
girl yeah it doesn't work like that you
know
and and but it's very expensive it's
expensive but it's very much so if you
had surgeries
um oh no not yet this is your hormones
it's making you look so feminine oh yeah
these are me oh yeah I accomplished
these I'm sorry yeah these are like I
accomplished these with um just taking
hormones being consistent on them and
things like that
um
yeah before I left home though like my
family didn't they they didn't see all
of this you know what I mean so it's
like it it's a struggle for me to go
back like I haven't been back home in
like nine how long it's been like nine
years
and you're happy yes you guys seem happy
yeah
what's the roughest part of this
lifestyle for you yeah the personal
personal life personal my personal life
um
it's just just being with just um
getting close to someone that just
trying to get closer to one or trying to
make people understand you it's a job by
yourself I'ma save the men in the mess
yes and many messes do not mix I swear
and that takes a big part of your life
it does if you're in love with a man
just describe a man on meth a man on
math it's it's it's always
um never faithful never faithful you um
it's always going to be um infidelity
infidelity if I'm saying the right
excuse me
um hallucinations
that's what I told her like 95 of the
time it's the crystal man so I had to
tell myself like okay I have to keep
keep keep saying because
um some people really lose it some
people really think really and like I do
I refuse to go back and forth over
something that is not true and it's only
because of the drug and then it's hard
to explain to someone that's high
because I know it's from experience when
you hide whatever you think and feel is
that's what you're gonna die for that
that's what you believe so there's no
proven you or trying to convince you
that it's not so I have to say 95 of the
time it's the dress but I say [ __ ] that
because it's like you have to excuse my
language but you have to look at you
have to look at the picture always like
one thing we always told each other is
no matter what it is you always look at
the picture and and if the picture might
seem a little off you know you got to
take your time out you got to put
yourself in other people's shoes when
you're dealing when you're on crystal
meth this is my evaluation you have to
like um put yourself in another person's
shoes like okay well maybe it could be
this way you always got to think for
every something always been a person to
have to think for the whole table like
I'm I'm leading us some we're going
somewhere me and her we're gonna take us
somewhere and we all all we got you know
see I always thought as a square male
that you guys would want to be women
meaning you would want to cut off your
male equipment and stuff like that no
it's because but you actually want to
keep it yeah because it's okay it's um
besides us being female us mentally
being female first for the we until we
are into men but man you have a man that
um don't want to see it or don't want to
touch it but they're there it's just a
thought it's the fetish it's about
fantasy it is the thought of me being
with or just like oh my god a woman with
the extra card versus a woman with
all the surgery and they were like well
I can go to get I can get me a real
female like it defeats the purpose of
them wanting to be with a trans I've
heard that trans women will make more
money on the street than uh yes we do
yeah that's true yeah but believe it or
not guys make make more money on the
streets yeah okay okay not dressed as a
woman
like yeah they just don't take advantage
of it because trans Community has made
it so easy and comfortable for them to
feel comfortable with us knowing that
when you think of a trash you
automatically think also she's going to
steal and she's going to get it and
she's prostituting yeah so a lot of
friends made it comfortable for man to
come in okay I ain't gonna do nothing
because they know the trans is going to
go they're going to work they're going
to get make sure everything is there a
lot of crazy drama when you guys get
picked up on the street I've I've been
took to Long Beach my first time in Long
Beach this is like our second one here
and I got um I was with a guy and I have
a sleeping like I I have sleep sleep
disorder and like so I was like
um I will crashed and
he's trying to leave me and I end up
going with I'm waking up in long story
short we end up leaving he actually
gotta trust don't say yeah sure we go to
Long Beach who goes to Compton and I
just feel this Eerie feeling and that
goes my first mind never been that
predicament never knew what I would do
if I was in that predicament I just felt
like something was crazy like something
was gonna happen here
um yeah they try to set me up I don't
know what was going what was going to
happen so I just hit it and like ran
from Long Beach to Compton to the train
station I don't know where I was going
it's crazy but you're never getting
beaten up or anything like that
um fighting just the fight yeah where
we're from more fights where we're from
like where you're from you're going to
this let's just do what you're gonna do
are you gonna leave home and
you should prepare yourself to have
because they're not gay friendly at all
I had tricks I had tricks I had tricks
that came up to me because I wouldn't
date them
and I'm fighting in the middle of the
street with this guy all because I
wouldn't date him and
um yeah I didn't put in some some crazy
ass situation where I went through I
went with this one guy because me and
her had a rule when we first came is
three days if I if I see you I have to
see we have to see each other in three
days like three days at the max you can
be gone the longest and this guy ended
up um taking me and I get in the car
with him and [ __ ] we goes all the way
like out fire it was out to Dina I know
what it is now but back then I didn't
know what it was where Altadena and I
thought I could have sworn and so I was
gonna [ __ ] kidnap me but I think I
talked my way out of it but you know and
then it was just like yeah it was crazy
as [ __ ]
oh yeah crazy I don't know I don't I
just told her we first movement I said
just know being here the most craziest
scariest filthiest nastiest weirdest
thing that you ever thought someone does
it here in California because California
has a little bit of some of all over the
world
all of them were so possibly being think
of is happening someone is doing it
actually into that and it's scary yeah I
have my friend try to sell me for a ball
these girls these guys do my uh my one
of my homegirls well I thought was my
homegirl she tried to this guy wanted to
meet me and [ __ ] and then she's trying
to she I'm not knowing she already
talking to him on the phone and [ __ ] and
coming to find out she's trying to
[ __ ] sell me and I'm not knowing and
and it's we in the room the room gets
crazy the guy's trying to [ __ ] lock
me in a [ __ ] closet all types
of [ __ ] and you know I had to [ __ ]
thank God I [ __ ] got out of there you
know I climbed out the [ __ ] bathroom
window and it was yeah we've been
through a lot here so it's been a lot
you have any regrets in your life
no look at me yeah
I know I love L.A what would you say is
the most important lesson you guys have
learned in your life
loyalty and Sanity
I tell people two things I own in this
world it's my Puss In My Sanity I
control those two
don't touch my man
I woke up in alleys with fingers this is
crazy like so much something happened it
didn't happen here like yeah
girl now you should let that out I'll
tell you it's crazy yes what about uh
are you doing this safely or sometimes
without a condom oh [ __ ] I'm gonna say
my favorite line
2013 I was diagnosed
with um HIV oh you're HIV possible yeah
so
um um
yes
but like but nowadays it seems like it's
the new orange like
even if you didn't
um acknowledge it they don't they don't
care as long as they have to if you have
to join they don't care so you guys will
have tricks will have unprotected sex
yes they will they some prefer it
thumbed out
um it all depends I usually judge a man
off if you don't have one on you that
means you can't we can we can't have it
because either for you uh actually yeah
you're not using it with no one else
yeah so it's just filthy like if I have
to ask you if you know we're gonna have
a encounter and you know you're coming
to me like of course you should already
have the condoms like you if if you
don't have the condom even if I do have
some you know and then that's when I
start charging oh yeah baby we got to go
get extra condoms and things like that
you know what I mean so it's like it's
not it's just all about how you finesse
it's finesse the situation it's like and
like because my ex-boyfriend um he I
just I watched him I watched him and he
I fell over somebody who who don't use
he don't believe in condoms
and he had sex and he's into both
female and men so uh yeah I can't um
yeah I've learned to know you know I
just keep prayers full and so you are
HIV negative or positive uh me I'm um I
don't want to disclose that okay but
um yeah I use protection I use
protection all the time
um
that's what I stand for you know I'm
like I try to I try to prevent you know
the next [ __ ] from you know not
even just you always got to protect
yourself like out there like like we
said before if I have to ask you to use
economists like uh you know
because people are out here really out
here trying to get you you know and it's
like I don't I didn't watch somebody who
I knew had HIV and I watched them
intentionally you know try to have sex
with me and then you know but you know
they always say it takes two you have to
because if you don't ask you know
um yeah
all right Shea and Zoe thank you so much
for sharing your stories thank you I
wish you guys lots of luck I hope you
guys do whatever you do safely I don't
know oh yeah I'm very excited thank you
thank you oh thank you guys for having
us um